if there's anyone who thinks that only
human beings can feel emotions like
sorrow and grief this footage will
change your mind
an elephant family in Kenya's Amboseli
National Park comes upon the bones of
their own matriarch as they tend to do
whenever they encounter any elephant
bones the elephant's first gather around
the bones in a defensive circle then
they turn the bones over picking them up
feeling every crevice
after this they touch the bones with
their hind feet scientists who have
studied elephant behavior are certain
that elephants experience deep emotions
and have some understanding about death
everything about the way these elephants
are grieving here proves that point